damn he puts a lot of fire and say his
gameplay ricky was talking about that
over there like you know he means those
but he wants those victories because of
those I mean so I got Intel from
no-pants earlier so that when kog'maw
was playing earlier today right nobody
was standing behind him and then nobody
just kept saying remember master come
remember when you bodied my team
remember how you messed it all up do
that today and this is kagemaru is but
when he's on a street like this on a hot
streak
it's his tournament I usually I mean you
know obviously he's in lose wreck right
now but he still has a good show this is
the story it's it gonna be kagemaru with
momentum in the unstoppable madness or
is it gonna be your first time playing a
musician in your body what is it which
lure is strong I mean I musician is
really good at stopping momentum as oh
he has a flash he has a long is that up
so yeah it's gonna be an interesting
matchup here man have you got your pad
versus Korea just like what you said
last representives it's gonna be Japan
Korea I musician can tomorrow all right
it's crazy to think that both Japan and
Korea are not even in the winners finals
that's crazy
Stuckey but Japan yeah man anyways we're
gonna go into the matchup here we go
this is a race to to one of these will
move on oh oh put the sword away don't
need it yet counter hit straight off the
five head coach Bobby nice adjustment
there it goes with the double knee level
Oh a buckle though see oh yeah special
awareness from a musician is so good he
knows how to get out of Dodge
look at his conversion and the wall with
y'all [ __ ] will break too oh man all
the mother thing can really stop
momentum and you know kagemaru is a very
momentum bass player five musician yeah
he got a deal with that flash better man
yeah you got a fire you got to find a
way to pump the brake and not be able to
you know just not going to the
transitions as much but he used it so
well earlier that you know I think he
just already has that like ya
implemented his own game plan Oh looky
knee the follow up here he's gonna push
towards the other side of the stage nice
yeah thanks for for for use not for so
well oh my god I would have saved it I
would say oh I have you go high position
takes the lead in the first match better
get your eyes checked disciple think the
table can handle the sieve this is
illegal you can't be flashing these
people
all right there you go things to follow
up but Eddie gets a wall break nice
right there as will puts himself and
Rach nice he's been landing so much
stuff
oh leg of Josie standing three look at
that final round here first game called
me he has to be careful because that was
oh I was I was thinking flash right
there - yeah oh here we go good
opportunity she's trying to test them
yeah
oh god oh yes fish stocks one cuz the
count had this pretty good for cocking
ball room again he's gotta be careful
though
block the walk I feel like II do who is
coming everyone knew but what you got
for us I musician why have you got for
us oh he's gonna you gonna flip again no
Swords Dance is it musician a pixel in
the dreams takes the first batch know
who's gonna win my death I mean the
presence of mine you know he he doesn't
have his sword out able to give that
sweep down only juggles without the
sword and capitalizing for that combo
damage man look at that he's broken the
curse how many times did he get the
flashing that lost my crease we bet you
that we said vital in this matchup flash
yeah yes he has more beads around he'll
tell you about it when you're older kids
there you go anyways we're gonna go
right into the matchup right now I'm
musician you know with the clutch combo
at the very end but is it gonna be
enough
remember that momentum when we talk
about kagemaru if he has a good feeling
that's gonna hurt but I mean the flash
it just it's the game changer right here
puts a stop to everything man and that's
gonna have to base out if you can't you
say it momentum you said that you say a
cocky model is a momentum play we've
seen it all day today
yeah he gets a good start over town for
two off the bat oh let me out
it wall attack just to get out trouble
right now yeah but now is in his favor
all try to set it up there and that was
might be the first flash it was he not
hit yeah and he actually got some damage
out of it this spirit away the super
flash nice akamaru deputy picking two
shots a lot better now not falling for
the flash I myself went down of olds it
yeah for three up lashes at five
musicians that one round oh it's a jab
out yep go off for sure yep she gets a
good open cat as well
nice oh that was really good
there's a spin gets the bag punished yes
puppies oh wow right there
baits they guess against the wall you
have to be careful he has got plenty
unblocking range available though
beautiful great sidewalk there avoided
that easily easy punished yep tied up
not one one oh he's waiting on the
flashes now yes usually have to take
momentum maybe using a bit too much
actually right now is knowing [ __ ]
don't make as aggressive is no more man
but that's time yeah you know he knows
how much he's done everything and how
much he'll keep doing it yeah he stopped
carrying here he's like you guys think
you're so smart
music okay you have to be careful right
here yeah final match at Korea vs. Japan
at the LCQ 2019 yes right now definitely
getting real right now
kagemaru staying alive in the bracket
right now is it gonna be I'm gonna say
Oh Ohio
you were saving that yeah over there my
pretty got a tie line once again see
it's a reversible anyway starting off
here final match bill walls it's gonna
be a test yeah that's a beautiful yeah
he's taking advantage of the fact that
this new twt rule of picking the stage
every time I musician gets the kicker
stage yeah always goes to infinite as
your Oh punishable it was just funny cuz
it's normally not the flashes have been
coming out car there was ever told work
that ice block that was a credible race
drive oh good blocks my god that was
crazy
Brooks dragons I'm position on set point
now to eliminate coming back from the
tournament Oh
Maru looking at Pease he might be a good
position
okay oh there goes the tournament for
models I'm using stays alive in this
bracket yeah Michonne sakakibara I wanna
show it boat line did really well took
out some killers in this tournament yo
guys make some noise for talking about
this Last Chance Qualifier showing and
been amazing nonetheless mmm he bounced
for the crowd but man you came backs
back as you probably could you remember
you were wearing the Korea yeah hey guys
we're in for a treat we have some long
sets coming up ahead next up is our
winners fine